alright i know the title of this video
sounds absolutely insane because the
iphone 13 hasn't even been revealed yet
but seeing as john prosser's incredible
leak of the iphone 14 pro's design hit
number five on twitter's trending list i
know a lot of people are asking this
question because in reality many of the
details surrounding the iphone 13 have
already been leaked including the design
with a new smaller notch and everything
like that but the iphone 14 design leaks
are showing the biggest change we've
seen to the iphone in many many years
and of course you probably shouldn't be
making major financial decisions based
on leaks especially ones that are an
entire year out but if you're kind of
unsure about buying the iphone 13 in the
first place the insane iphone 14 leaks
that i'm gonna be analyzing in this
video could be enough to get you to wait
it out for another year and i'll help
you make that decision at the end of
this video so before i get into what i
think about each little detail that john
leaked and if i think it makes sense
from apple's perspective i want to
quickly mention our new m1x chip t-shirt
design which you can find in our merch
shelf right below this video now before
we begin i want to mention that john
prosser successfully leaked the design
of various apple products months before
they were actually revealed like apple's
air tags which ended up looking exactly
like his renders or the airpods max
which looked incredibly similar or the
multi-colored imac design leak that was
really close to the real deal except for
the missing chin don't forget that he
showed us the iphone 13 smaller notch
way back in december of last year he
also showed us the design of the apple
watch series 7 months ago which many
analysts now agree on and the same thing
goes for the design of the ipad mini 6
that we're expecting to come soon so
when it comes to design leaks john
prosser has some pretty reliable sources
he doesn't always get every detail right
but he gets close now as far as these
new iphone 14 design leaks i know there
are some incredible changes like the
flush glass back with no camera bump as
well as the single hole punch camera on
the front but i want to get started with
other details like john claiming that
it's going to have a titanium finish
first off i want to make it clear that
the titanium finish will likely only be
available on the pro models since that's
one of the ways apple differentiates the
regular models from the higher end ones
so there's a good chance that the low
end iphone 14 will stick with aluminum
but maybe i'm wrong who knows but if you
think the whole titanium finish is
totally random it's not way back in
january apple filed for patents that
include using a new titanium alloy for
various products like macbooks ipads
iphones and apple watches and the whole
point of that is that it would allow
apple to make thinner devices while
maintaining the same durability and
probably giving it better micro scratch
resistance a month after that another
patent was filed by apple for
anti-fingerprint coatings for future
titanium devices and then in july
another report came out claiming that
the iphone 14 pro models will feature a
titanium alloy chassis so they totally
agree with john and finally last month
digitimes claim that apple is working on
future ipads with titanium alloy chassis
designs so it seems like apple wants to
switch all of their products over to
this new alloy in the future but as far
as john prosser's iphone 14 titanium
finish leak i totally agree with them
and i think it's gonna help make it feel
more premium than ever before now moving
on to the next piece of info we have
those wild looking speaker grills or
slots on the bottom of the iphone 14 pro
since it was a bit difficult to see the
close-up details from his video i headed
over to his website frontpagetech.com
and scrolled all the way down to the
bottom of the iphone 14 leak article and
i downloaded the full res images which
are available to the public and taking a
closer look you can see that the speaker
slots have a very fine mesh grille
inside of them and this closely
resembles the speaker grilles on the old
iphone 4 which jon says the iphone 14
design is based on now i personally
think that this is going to be a pretty
awesome change and because of the
stronger titanium alloy finish you
shouldn't really worry about the thin
metal areas surrounding the speakers
bending or breaking and i think apple is
going to use this opportunity to make
the speakers sound much better than they
currently do but the interesting detail
to notice is that the leaked renders and
cad files of the apple watch series 7
from john also include these long
speaker slots that are kind of similar
to what john showed us with the iphone
14 so maybe apple is going that route
for the speakers on both of those
products now as far as those circular
volume buttons john says that they're
there because apple seems to be going
retro again so maybe apple is gonna mix
it up with those new buttons but i
personally prefer the current volume
buttons because they seem more
convenient but i guess we'll see now as
far as the iphone 14 keeping the same
lightning port it makes perfect sense
for apple because it doesn't seem like
they have polished their mac safe
technology enough to the point where
they can ditch the lightning connector
because they're gonna need to charge
very fast
and the max safe is gonna have to
transfer data which i'm sure they're
gonna solve in the near future but now
getting into the biggest design changes
let's start with the completely flush
single piece of glass on the back that
doesn't have any kind of camera bump the
glass part of it seems totally
believable because apple is already
doing this with the front glass on the
24 inch imac which extends further than
the metal chassis except it's definitely
going to be a bit more risky in terms of
dropping your iphone 14. but the detail
about the camera bumps being completely
flush is the hardest part to believe
because it would require the iphone to
be a lot thicker to fully encompass the
notch and make it flush and what makes
this difficult is that the iphone 13 pro
is rumored to have a notch that sticks
out even more than the iphone 12 pro max
and that could easily carry over to the
14. on top of that minchiko claimed that
the iphone 14 pro will come with a new
48 megapixel sensor with 8k video
recording which definitely doesn't help
make the camera modules any less thick
but john did say that the iphone 14 is
gonna be a very thick phone compared to
what we have now with the iphone 12
models and i guess there's a chance that
apple could somehow free up space on the
inside of the iphone to allow the camera
to sit a bit deeper into the phone than
before but who knows however there are
some other leakers like mori qhd on
twitter who disagree with jon about the
totally flushed cameras on the back of
the iphone 14. but moving on finally we
have the biggest change which is the
notchless display with a single hole
punch camera layout which is probably
one of the most controversial details
that john leaked for a couple of
different reasons first off apple
usually has a three-year redesign cycle
for major design changes like the full
redesign with the iphone 6 the full
redesign with the iphone 10 and the flat
side redesign with the iphone 12. so if
apple kept that cycle going that would
mean that the iphone 15 in 2023 would be
getting the next big redesign but jon
claims that apple is gonna break the
cycle and do it a full year earlier than
expected and in my recent video about
the iphone 13's smaller notch i
mentioned that it would be weird for
apple to redesign the notch this year
and then do it again the very next year
because if you think about it apple
milked the current notch for four years
in a row and people still bought the
iphone 12 in record numbers so i
basically predicted that apple could
keep the iphone 13 smaller notch for
another year and then switch to the hole
punch design with the iphone 15 but i
may actually be wrong for a couple of
different reasons first off what if
apple realized that they're far behind
the competition in terms of the notch so
they've gotta act sooner than later to
get rid of it and that would totally
make sense but going even further the
reliable analyst ming chakro mentioned
back in march that some 2022 iphone 14
models could abandon the notch in favor
of the punch hole display design so i
guess if apple kept the notch on the
lower end iphone 14 models but switched
to a hole punch on the pro models that
would greatly help differentiate them
because if you think about it the iphone
12 and the 12 pro have barely any
differences right now so apple needs
something else to keep the pro model
exclusive and worth the extra cash and
on top of that there are rumors that
apple is ditching the mini sized model
next year and replacing it with another
6.7 inch max sized model so apple will
essentially have two 6.7 inch iphones
the iphone 14 max and the iphone 14 pro
max and if this happens the whole punch
display panel would be perfect to help
differentiate the two models and guess
what just happened ross young a display
analyst on twitter actually confirmed
that theory with a chart he revealed
back in june showing the punch hole
display on the iphone 14 pro models and
a notch on the regular models to help
differentiate them going even further
mark german himself actually mentioned
that the smaller notch on the iphone 13
will be followed by an even smaller
notch on the iphone 14 and in my opinion
the only way that makes sense is if
apple goes with the hole punch design
and finally mori qhd on twitter the same
guy who disagreed about the flush
cameras actually agreed with jon about
the new notchless display panel which he
says he leaked a week ago and this shows
the new speaker grille at the top of the
display which matches up to the expected
grille on the iphone 13. so if apple is
going with the hole punch design like
john showed off the way they're going to
be doing it is by integrating all of the
face id sensors into one large sensor
just like they've already done with the
lidar scanner on the back of the iphone
12 pro and then placing that new sensor
directly underneath the display and if
apple isn't able to pull that off by
next year for whatever reason there's a
chance they'll go with a dual hole punch
design which was recently leaked by
shrimp apple pro but nevertheless these
new renders by ian's elbow are
absolutely amazing so definitely go and
give him a follow on twitter and by the
way he says he's very confident in these
design details because they're based on
a combination of real images cad files
and schematics and with all that said
let's finish off with the original
question should you wait for the iphone
14 or just buy the iphone 13 which will
be revealed in less than a week well if
you really don't mind the notch you also
prefer a thinner iphone and you really
want the new 120hz display and other
features like portrait video recording
then you'll probably be happy with the
iphone 13. going further if you're not
planning on buying the more expensive
pro model then there's even less reason
to wait because there's a good chance
the lower iphone 14 models will continue
to have the same notch as the iphone 13
instead of having a hole punch display
but if you're totally happy with your
current iphone and you're kind of on the
fence about the 13 i would honestly
suggest waiting for the iphone 14 pro
because that is gonna have the biggest
redesign we've seen in years and it's
going to help it hold its value much
better compared to previous notched
iphones since it'll be coming with
features like the new titanium chassis
the flush back glass the new speaker
grille layout the hole punch display and
massively upgraded cameras like a 48
megapixel sensor that can shoot 8k video
so hopefully you learned something new
from this video and if you did go ahead
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one and
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]